[Music]
this is from a long time ago ryan you
and i went on the smallest tour we ever
went on in 2013. we called it the
alberta mini tour right it was june of
2013 and i believe colin wright went
with us we lived in montana at the time
we drove up from missoula and went to
calgary in edmonton
and this essay came from that experience
one of our tour stops up there at a
chapters bookstore in calgary
a few years back during our first tour
of the maple leaf leaf north we stood
amid alphabetical rows of endless
bookshelves basking in calgaries in a
calgary bookstore's fluorescent glow
answering questions at the end of our
talk in front of a few hundred smiling
canadians
and then
a heckler
it happens in almost every city someone
projects their fears expectations and
insecurities onto us
you guys aren't real minimalist because
you drive a car you own a smartphone you
sell books you
whatever it happens so frequently that
we're now
inoculated to the criticism
whenever you do something meaningful
people will judge you so
the what
let them judgment is but a mirror that
reflects the insecurities of the person
who's doing the judging
but this time
in this albertan bookshop
it was different
toward the back of the crowd a man in
his mid-40s raised his hand and in an
aggressive tone said i don't have a
question
i have a comment
the crowd hushed
waited
i had to get rid of my bed because of
you two the heckler said
excuse me ryan said
because of this whole minimalism thing
my wife and i had to get rid of our bed
he said louder this time furrowing his
brow and gesturing toward the woman at
his right
why i asked
we've never told anyone to get rid of
their own bed
i own a bed
ryan owns a bed
i wouldn't
i don't think you understand me he
interrupted
his arms gesticulating wildly a manic
look on his features
my wife found your website earlier this
year and we had to get rid of our bed
but why would you our marriage was
ending he cut in again
after two decades we had become
roommates not a married couple we were
staying together just for the kids
the entire crowd was rubbernecking now
staring at the couple
then my wife found your website and she
started simplifying without telling me
she was letting go of everything that
didn't add value to our lives
uh oh ryan mudder
that's right she found your 2020 rule
and then your 90-90 rule she was even
playing the minimalism game with her
friends
hmm
i pondered aloud
in just a few months but in just a few
months i noticed something was different
our house was cleaner
tidier less cluttered but more important
something was different with my wife
she seemed happier calmer
less stressed
and she was being nicer to me which
forced me to notice how
um
not nice i was being to her
and to our kids
and to everyone in my life but then i
realized i could be nice too
my wife had changed so that meant
i could change too it was my decision
we both nodded and continued listening
maybe this wasn't a heckler after all
for the first time in years he said
with much of our excess junk out of the
way my wife and i started talking again
we were actually communicating
with each other
we started having discussions we hadn't
had in years dreams goals priorities
everything was on the table
a huge smile broke across the man's
glowing face
then something amazing
we started having sex again
lots of sex
crazy sex great sex so much sex that our
teenage kids complained that our bed was
too loud
he clapped his hands to mimic their
headboard banging against the wall bang
bang bang bang
laughter overcame the crowd
so we got rid of our bed too
and with less stuff
we found ourselves
we found the couple who had been buried
underneath decades
of clutter
what essays called
less stuff more sex he baited us so good
those he intentionally baited us he did
a really good job of it too what a
brilliant man to take that risk because
at any point you guys could have felt
like this was getting out of control and
just like cut him off and end at the
moment i mean that does happen though
yeah and so for him to take that chance
that's true just to be able to get that
dramatic effect oh
that's a good story would you i don't
think i'd ever cut some unless they were
being belligerent or something i don't
think i would cut someone off though
well i remember in boston recently
someone was pretty drunk and it was like
lisa lampanelli was there we were
finally like all right lady you have to
like right there's a question mark at
the end of this right yeah and i will do
that quite often in our live events
making sure that their statement is
appended with some sort of question
because otherwise it's it's
well it's kind of rude to the other
people who are there to experience the
event right yeah we're not there for
that person we're there for the whole
audience yeah but tk you're right man
like he he didn't know that we wouldn't
cut him off i mean that's that was a
pretty big risk and he he he did i just
he bet it is so good my heart's starting
to pump i'm like oh my goodness like i'm
gonna have to like
you know address this criticism yeah no
it was great the moral of the story is
there are unexpected benefits of
simplifying yes they had less clutter in
their lives but their marriage was
essentially over and now they were
having so much sex
that their kids were complaining and the
funny thing is about this i remember we
moved into our new house and bex and i
have a lot of sex
bex rhymes with sex
my god you guys have your pick-up line
yeah yeah yeah yeah
we might
now realizing that
uh sexy bexy she doesn't like when i
call her that but i do all the time
and we talk about that on her podcast
how to love and uh one thing that we
noticed when we first moved into our new
house is
we placed ella's bedroom next to ours
and i was like oh
this can
and i thought of this essay that i wrote
from back in 2013 i said oh no no no
like
we're loud and so like we need
we had two bedrooms ella's bedroom needs
to go as far away as possible and so we
just moved her to the other side and now
we have an office and a bathroom two
bathrooms in between us at this point
and it just provided enough sound
dampening that we can still have fun in
the bedroom and we got to keep our bed
so
how great is that
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com slash the minimalists
or click the link in the description
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free